Welcome everybody to another zoom call or do the best to answer your questions that you send in or chat in
Reminder to everybody to please please please use the member site. So the member site shows all the annulled spins
No other big annulled spins, even though I did hear that true rife sent out an email today that you can
Download version 6.4 off the website now over high-look did you still can't
So I don't know what is about that if you do download 6 version 6.4
Make sure you contact us because you will lose all your programs. So there's a way to do it
Way to do it correctly you either said it to us and have us do it for you
And I'll put all your programs on it. I'll make sure all your programs are up to 6.4 standards because some people's may not be
Or you do it yourself through the instructions on the member site and the rife course site
And those instructions look like this
So you can go over that yourself
However your program that I'm created for you even if you follow all these
Instructions and you save the program and you then put it back on a level
As per these instructions it still might not be up to version 6.4. You still might need
Be to send you a new program. So I suggest you said it to us to have us do it if you want your
Program updated to 6.4. However
They're coming out with a 7.0 very soon. So just wait
Okay, first question. I'm in the hospital right now and they're draining off
love and tummy fluid
I will try to get results to you did not see any results
um
Right prior to this meeting. So looking again no no results
So um
I know other information all my liver enzymes have gone
up. I must soon be going
Gone a lot. I'm assuming so we that she means they went up a lot
I did break my rife and I've been running the liver program under body function
Frequency set. Is there anything else I should be doing sounds like I will be here a few days
Yes, I would say make sure you're running your cancer programs
So make sure you're running your cancer programs because it is the cancer
It's causing the ascites you know not failure of the liver or something
So make sure you're running the cancer programs
A person sent in their signature test
To ask to kind of go over it to understand what the signature test is looking at
So the signature test this part of it is testing for what's called
cell-free
DNA or CF-DNA
A cell-free DNA is the same thing that for those that have been with me for a number of years
It's the same thing that the IBG test tested for
So there's value in measuring cell-free DNA
Matter of fact, you could do a google search on a cell-free DNA
And it will tell you that cell-free DNA was it was a really
You know what it first was discovered to be able to be tested levels in the blood
There was a lot of excitement because it can tell you if first it has cancer
Before a lot of other objective tests can tell you
So it is still used in different tests the cologard test
That is very widely advertised on TV is a cell-free DNA test
That's you see that same technology the IBG test that we used to do is a cell-free DNA test
However that company went out of business during COVID
Is there a try to keep their prices down and sell to doctors like me to sell to patients where as like cologard
using the exact same technology
Charges like $2,500 but they're going only through insurance and only through medical doctors
in order to to make a profitable business
Signature does you know close through doctors like me and other doctors that are doing alternative care
But it's more expensive test
And that's where IBG had to either raise their price either like triple their price to stay in business
And they just could not get they just have the advertising budget there a small lab
Even though they were clear proof of lab they just couldn't stay in business
So cell-free DNA can be measured at different times in the level of cell-free DNA
It is not to then correspond to the level of
You know cancer so if the if that level goes up
Then the the ideas that the cancer is getting worse if that level goes down and the cancer is getting better. You're recovering
However, we have seen with when we used the IBG test for the three years that they were in business that that wasn't always the case
and so
Just like any other test
You cannot count on one test
This person's results actually show the cell-free DNA going down here over time
um
One done
earlier in 2023 to
August September 2023 to this time that it's going down
And the person's conditioning condition appears to be
Not moving in its same good direction seems to be moving in a worse direction sometime
So it's very difficult to use one test to monitor this
So I tell you even with doing a CT scan or an MRI or using tumor marker tests
You know sometimes when you're actually getting better and your cancers dying the tumor marker tests could spike
giving you a false
positive that you think you're getting worse
well the
Cell-free DNA can actually go down when your when the cancer's growing too
So it's can be confusing why is it because no test is perfect
They're just even though things are a gold standard. There really isn't anything
Now a visual presentation of the tumor in tests like a CT scan or an MRI maybe
Consider the gold standard solely because
You can physically see that the size of the tumor is getting larger if you have a solid tumor
And you could use a CT or an MRI
A PET scan isn't
Technically a visual field test. It's measuring uptake of glucose and increase in metabolic rate
But it's kind of the same line
Whereas a blood test like this or a tumor marker test
Is measuring an outcome of cancer growth or cancer death
So again, no test is perfect. You look at one test and you compare it with
Other objective tests and you compare it with subjective findings meeting your son of symptoms and
you know, you know
What else is going on in your body? How you're feeling
Other signs like I'm getting fluid in my abdomen or I'm getting a sighties built up
And the sighties is getting worse on a weekly basis. I mean, they have to drain more each week
That would be a sign that the cancer is getting worse or it's getting better and I'm getting
You know, even though there was there was 1500 milligrams milliliters taken out
One time now it's you know now we're only taking out 750
Milliliters every week or every two weeks. Well, that would be getting better
So you you don't measure just one test. You look at as many tests as possible
Is a different person saying I would like to try that bed is all
Why not? How much should someone like me 89 pounds take and for how long
Is there anything else to be aware of while taking it?
Well fed bed is all is
Protocol that is been widely called widely known as the joe tibans protocol
because
It's a guy named joe tibans who I believe had lung cancer and
um
He used this fed bed is all protocol and got better and he's still alive today
Where they had just given him weeks or months to live
So fed bed is all is used um not by itself. So
His protocol was to take fed bed so that's what you call it for short
um wait come on spill check
So um it takes fed bed and then uh take curcumin
take um
uh apop e which is the um
The type of e that
The delta-total tree and all type of e
and then
Then he expanded it to taking burberry as well
And then also taking a CBD oil
So that was this is the joe tibans protocol
Now if you just call our office we actually have these in packs and you could start taking it
Now then how much of the fed bed is all does someone take
Um typically in joe tibans standard protocol of somebody who is either low weight
Um or their cancer is it all that aggressive um you just do one packet per day now the the
Product of fed bed is all that we have is
One packet is for a 10 pound dog. So
That doesn't seem like a very high dose because it's not it's a very very low dose of fed bed is all
But he recommended um and some
Veteran areas that recommend this protocol and alternative doctors that recommend this protocol is that you do
Up that dose depended on weight
If you weigh 200 pounds you probably have to take two or three packets a day
But it also depends like if your cancer is fairly stable and you just want to try the
Tipans protocol you might just start with one packet a day
Um if you weigh 240 pounds and your cancer is aggressive you might take three packets a day
The other thing about this protocol you only do the fed bed is all
um four days a week
So you do the
Everything else
Every day, but you do the fed bed is all four days a week
So Monday through Thursday you would take the fed bed then
Friday Saturday Sunday you would only take these
Um, excuse me Monday through Thursday you would take all of these and then Friday and Saturday Sunday you would only take
Um, these things so everything except the
Most of the curse is not working
Uh, everything except the fed bed
But again, if you have a very aggressive cancer and you're getting worse
And your cancer is continuing to, you know
Grow then you change that dosage you don't really change the dosage that percumin a puppy burberry and CBD
Which changed the doses of the fed bed you might take it daily
So when we test people
Full red eye tests for how many packets and how how many days a week so
Um, it's all over the board and it does have to do with the person's weight
Uh, body weight started off and it has to do with that person's
aggressiveness of the cancer
And fed bed can be used really for any cancer
Uh, I would say any cancer except
Typically it's not used for brain cancers
Um, yeah, so and it's typically not used for the the leukemia's
So any solid tumor cancer
Um, minus the brain cancers um, I've never had a test for anybody with brain cancer
But anybody else you could try it. I mean, there's really, you know
The only side effects that I've ever had anybody say to me is that it
Gave a little tummy ache and I gotta say I was not convinced that it was the fed bed that gave him the tummy ache
Could have been something else the capsules of the supplements are taken. It's how it is a powder
It comes in a little packet you put it in a smoothie really doesn't have any taste
I remember one packet is what you'd give a 10-pug dawn for helping it the worm so um, it's way under
Dosed for a human now you can get the bedbed is all which is the human form when fed bed is all which is the really the exact same thing
Um, but it's much more expensive and a lot of people
Would rather just get this and then they don't have to go and get it
Um, by the doctor that's gonna give him a prescription for
My wrist bones below my thumbs still hurt pretty bad
Even the skin hurts
Um, my fingers are stiff and my thumbs lock up every morning when I wake up
I bought a new thumbs CMC restrictions split and I've been worried for one day
So not sure how much it is helping
I take a lot of tumeric proteolytic enzymes and even when I was taking 800 milligrams of ibuprofen three times a day after surgery had no effect on this
I tried to see me detoxically and also dmso
Is there something I'm missing
A supplement maybe a rife program while I'm watching TV or something
Is it a lack of estrogen from the horrible blockers causing the tend to this tendinitis or the aroma taste inhibitors
They have ward off since I have not had an injection over two months and I'll longer have hot flashes
So you I would say they've ward off in your estrogen your
Healthy estrogens are coming back into balance, but the pain is not diminished yet
Maybe it takes longer. Thanks. So
With anything on my first thing is we got to you got to try to figure out why right so why do you have this?
Um, if it was from a restriction of estrogen
um
Yeah, that's not something that I've heard of as having you know
Musculoskeletal type pain from the restriction of estrogen
Um, so I don't think it was from the aroma taste inhibitor
Is it from the chemotherapy drug
We probably so there's plenty of
uh documentation that chemotherapy drugs can give you
uh, have been foot syndrome which is really a peripheral neuropathy type situation where
The chemotherapy medication damages the nerves
So
That's probably what it was um
So underopathy so a neuropathy is when
uh
The aetherid pathway of the nerve is damaged so aetherid pathway of a nerve is the
Derve that carries sensory input back to the brain
What carries motor import put back to the muscle is the aetherid pathway
So that's your brain telling your muscle to contract
But would you feel pain numbness tingly vibration hot and cold
Those are carried from the tissue site back to the brain
So you have different receptors in your skin for those things you have different receptors in your joints
You have receptors in your
uh subcutaneous fat layer
So that when you touch a stove or you feel heat it fires
Uh, they're back to the braid and tells the braid in the ride alone
That there's heat and then that fires in order to the front alone telling you
There's heat and then your braid processes that and fires um an aether an aetherid
um
signal to the muscle to jerk your head away from that stove or out of that out of danger
So what a reflex is is a reflex picks up
uh
A sensory input and it goes only back to the cord does not go back to the braid and fires back to the aetherid pathway
And jerks that nerve back so you do have sort of reflexes too
Now
neuropathy is when something damages the nerve so
The most common form of neuropathy is diabetic neuropathy so it's a increased glucose levels that damage the nerves
And it's typically going to damage well when you have a chemically reduced neuropathy it's going to damage the nerves
um in the periphery meaning that the fingers and the hands and the toes and the feet because
You know, how do you
Would you have a chemical circulating your body and then it dissipates into the tissues
It's going to have the most difficult time getting out of the peripheral
areas because of just the location
So that chemical is going to settle there and it could damage those nerves now
because of
The way
Your nerves are
They there are what are called small diameter afference and large diameter afference
It's the large diameter afference that carry these signals
of the of peed in and
tingling
That's what's carried on the large diameter afference and they're the most susceptible to damage because of
The physical attributes of the nerve sheath
so
with
Emotherapy adductoropathy or diabetic
adductoropathy glucose levels and being high rates high levels can damage that that large
diameter
Efferent pathway, which is going to be you're going to start to feel numbness to glean pain
type things
Well, then what do you do? So you have to a work on trying to pull out that chemical
How do you do that? Well, that's where
using the ion pro wave on your hands
So you run the ion pro wave putting your hands in the bucket can be helpful
using magnesium
Baths if your hands just put in your hands in an epsom salt bath in a little bucket
can be helpful
Saunas make sure you're getting your hands in the sauna so that you're
You're sweating through your hands can be helpful
Your lymphatic drainage hold your hands above your
Above your head and make sure you're exercising and moving it so you move that chemistry out of there
But if you what do you do once there's already damaged to those nerve pathways
Well, then you have to stimulate those nerve pathways to heal
And you might be looking at wanting to get that tool called the rebuilder
so the rebuilder is
The
apparatus that is was created specifically for neuropathy
It's separate from the
From the true right
It is FDA approved. It's got tons of studies on it for
benefiting people with the rapidity of any kind of any type
So it's if you look on our website. It's called the rebuilder
um, it's called rebuilder 300
I'll pull up a picture of it for you
And so you can see what it looks like, but it looks like a little tens unit
But it's very different than a tens unit. It's the way it
It's the way it works and the way it fires into your hands or your feet
You also have a bucket of water, but it has to be a split bucket. So you have to go to
There's information on our
Store about the rebuilder itself. So you can look at that
um
But I literally we've sold dozens and dozens and dozens of these
For a decade we sold these for a long time and people had a really good success with them
I got an ultrasound on my right
Accela axillary area because I felt the lump and it turned out to be residual
Cerroba from the surgery. They also noted this multiple morphological benign lymph nodes
We're noted in the right axilla with thin cortices and fatty hyla
What I scanned my left side or comparison they found this
comparative imaging on the left axilla
Demonstrates two adjacent abnormal lymph nodes with thickened cortices measured up to four millimeters
Now they want to do a biopsy of one of these
Would these be new after surgery? I don't know if they were there
When they clipped in large lymph nodes before surgery does this mean if the biopsy is positive that my current program is not helping to stop recurrence
I am supposed to get my implant surgery in January 8
Can I ask them to just remove those two lymph nodes while they're there?
I just got this information yesterday. I'm not supposed to be a psychologist or by surgeon
Yet, I don't know what to do with this new information the thoughts
Well, let's do this question first. Just got this information. Don't haven't spoken to them yet
So you need to talk to your doctor about
whether they can remove those lymph nodes
um
They may push hard for getting a biopsy to see what they are first
And then if they
Because the truth is is that if
From their standpoint if these are cancerous, they're not going to want to do this um this um
um
Implant surgery. I don't think I think that might be off the table if these are cancerous
Um, they'll be pushing hard for radiation or something like that
So
We just don't know yet, you know, we just don't know as far as this question does this mean if the biopsy is positive the my current program
I think you're talking about your nutrition your diet your right is not helping stop your occurrence
This is a common
Thought in people's mind
Because my cancer is getting worse
Does it mean everything I'm doing just didn't work? Well
The answer is
Yes, in a way it didn't work the way you wanted it to work meeting it didn't make all your cancer go away
And you don't have any problem right now
But the truth is is that
What if you weren't doing everything you were doing the truth is you you could have been dead six months ago
I mean, you just don't know that you don't know how
Well, everything you're doing is holding things at bay
You know for as long as it possibly can um
There's
There's only the bottom lies. There's only so much human control. You have over your life
Um, I know we all want to feel especially those that live in America
Feel like we have more control over our destiny and that if we just make changes that we can change our destiny
I'll guarantee you just in time that I spent as a missionary in Mexico
Where there was just another we're working with just the destitute impoverished people
They didn't come from the feeling and the background that they could change their current situation by making a few different decisions in life
Um, there was some things that they just couldn't change. I mean there was just
You know almost an impossibility of getting out of their situations
But we in America think that because we have had such affluence and
Because we're taught to be
relatively narcissistic in our philosophy even in our churches
That we have control over our destiny and to a certain extent we do we were given free will we can choose our diet
We can choose our lifestyle. We can choose our partner. We can choose a lot of things
But
God constantly reminds us that we can't choose everything you can't choose whether
Your heart's going to continue to beat or not even if you do everything right
I can't tell you how many people I talk to on a weekly basis that's
Say things like I just can't believe I got cancer. I've been living this you know, you know
We've been only eating organic for 20 years
Our we've been doing you know
Fill in the blank and you think that
Because you're doing good things right about arguing that eating correctly and taking good nutrition and
Doing making good lifestyle choices are probably going to give you better outcomes than if you did otherwise
But it doesn't mean that we're going to be
You know immune from heart disease or you know cancer or vascular problems or a stroke or
You know getting run over by a train. So
Things happen that are beyond our control. We live in a fallen world and you do everything
I believe that from a biblical perspective. We're supposed to do everything worst. We can do
To an extent if we become obsessed with
Getting our way whether our way is to be cured of a disease
Or our way is to be financially independent or our way is to be rich or wealthy
Or our way is to have the perfect relationships
Or all our way is filling the bank. What is it that you want in life?
Well, we've been programmed and conditioned
To get what we want and to fight for and and uh, you know make goals of
Achieving that which we want and in one sense you can say that's a noble achievement
But in other sense we have to be very careful
That we don't step over that line into a golletry and self-indulgence and
And complete darsacistic behavior and being obsessively compulsive about our
self
And and our darsacistic thoughts
Um, that's something especially Americans more than other people have to fight against if you talk about your
Your daily fight against your flesh that they're possible. Paul spoke about
He probably didn't have in the first century Christians didn't have the same fight that we have as Americans
We live in affluence and we are stricken with affluenza and
Thinking that we get our way all the time and I'm not saying everybody's on this call because you want to get rid of your cancer
You want to get healthy and what the heck are you a doctor for if you're saying that you don't have control of these things
I'm saying you do everything you possibly can without becoming
Obsessive about it. You do everything you possibly can
Ultimately, you have to leave the results to God it ultimately
Everything that happens to us is supposed to if we're believers we claim to be believers
It's supposed to drive us to a deeper relationship with him
Um, otherwise what what what is there a reason for living but other than to glorify God
And to express his kingdom on earth through our love for other people and and for me at least I'll just speak for myself
I have to die to myself on a daily basis and die to my desires and die to my wants
If my cancer comes back, I'm gonna be very disappointed
But then I have to is a mature believer get over that pretty quick
Are there some things I need to change and get back on my diet probably
I'm doing the more right things yes, but if my cancer continues to progress in it
And I get and I'm gonna continue downhill and tell my
death then you know
I have to
accept that and bring him glory through that and um
That's it gets I'm not saying it's not it's it's not gonna it's not hard
But I'm just saying that that is really
The good fight that we all must strive for and that is the good life that um
That that we that we need to aim for that's the goal we need to aim for is to hear well done good and faithful servant who were done with this
With this path
I'm not talking directly to this person everybody just wants to get better. I'm talking to myself more than anything else
So I don't think I'm
I'm you know
Harp it on anybody here. So I'm harp it on myself and it's a reminder that that that that's that's our good fight that we have to work on every day
It's dying to ourself
Yes, do everything we can do but then we
We ultimately have to surrender to the case. It's not a mind way. It's God's way and he's got a plan of this
Okay, I bring him glory through it
Question from the chat on the true right programs under my name. There's a program called short day program
I would I click on it nothing happens
but
Okay, well I'll have to look at that on your program it might be a little glitch in there to copy right
So
I won't be able to do it till
Monday probably but I'll look at your program
If you can send me an email to email me that would be great
Does a sighties only occur in the abdomen?
No
But a sighties all will occur in the body cavities so a sighties will occur in the abdominal cavity and in the plural
cavity so in the lungs
So really in the lungs you can get a sighties in the pericardial sac but that gets very serious
You don't typically get a sighties in the pericardial sac from cancer though
But you can't get a sighties of the pericardial sac from
from
Pericardial infection and that could be deadly
That's what was happening post with these with these
COVID vaccines
That's where people would just basically drop dead because they got fluid in the
And the pericardial sac and basically squash the heart that it wouldn't can't be till you die
But so from cancer you get can get a sighties in the lungs you can get a sighties in the abdominal cavity
Uh, the best thing to do is to make sure if you do get a sighties
fluid in the abdominal cavity or the lungs your body can't drain that but
I tell you just feel a hundred times better when you go get that drained
Pressure on your lungs or pressure in your abdominal cavities from from
You know, I've had people have five liters of fluid taken off of
It off the developmental cavity. Can you imagine five liters of fluid?
What that's doing to squash your organs and fill your body up
It's just carried that around. It's not good to get that drained. It can be really really beneficial
It's been been good for a metastatic prostate cancer. Yes, it can be
It can't be it's it's certainly worth trying there really isn't a downside of fendman
So if you and back to that fendman question, you know, that was the
Where'd I go over that?
That was the protocol. Well mostly you guys are already taking curcumin a poppy and many of you are already taking burberry and CBD
So just adding the fendman is all
Would be while the many of you would have to do to do that
Can you run through the Joe Tippen's days of dosage for fendman and the other components
No, again
It depends on the protocol so the standard protocol for somebody who's not doesn't weigh a lot
and
Their cancer isn't extremely aggressive at this time would be one packet a day for four days a week
Along with curcumin a poppy burberry and CBD
And and it's typically three curcumin a day
I think it's two a poppy a day and three burberry today and one dropper for the CBD
It's a liquid dropper
entourage
And one packet which is about you know about
Half a tablespoon of that packet you just put it in a smoothie and
Really has no taste if you weigh two hundred pounds you might do two packets a day four days a week
And you can play with that dose of fendman
I have some people that are doing three packets a day seven days a week because their cancers aggressive at this time
But they're hitting it really hard with this
I've had lots of people turn their cancer around with that so
It's something to worth investigating
I think I misspoke when I asked about whether the aromatase it has been or cause the tendonitis from what I've heard and read a woman on estrogen blockers
Do get joint pain? I was just wondering whether it was because the drugs themselves or to a lack of estrogen or
Maybe it was the
Kiscarly I think it was the Kiscarly
um
Which I haven't taken since September but that's
Not usually a side effect usually it causes low white blood cell count um
I don't think it I mean
um
Your estrogen levels after you've been off this we'll go back into the normal range and um
So you know you looking at you know if it is the neuro if it isn't a
Ropathy then I would treat it with what I said
um
tendonitis might be something different maybe you had weakening of a tendon and you strained something but typically a tendonitis wouldn't heal over time
Um, and if it seems to not be getting any better than
Um, you have to look at other sources getting an x-ray done in the area getting an LRI done in the area would be wise
Could lack of estrogen another possibility, which I think would be remote um is
um, when you could actually lose blood flow to a bone
It's called osteo necrosis and um, baby
You end up because of a lack of estrogen ended up with
Uh, osteo necrosis of one of your carpal bones
Uh, you're
If if you remember falling at it or they were injured or something like that, that's a possibility too
Maybe you're more susceptible to that
That's that's not an uncommon injury from a fall
Especially the scaphoid or the lune carpal bones
But um, that would be visible on an x-ray
So get some investigation done maybe by a local doctor would be helpful too
Maybe it's totally a musculoskeletal thing
Not under or there are apathy's musculoskeletal, but it's not maybe it's not under apathy
So acides cannot occur in the deck correct
correct, so acides would not be
Uh, would not be if you could get swelling it's could you could get fluid buildup anywhere
But typically that's not called acides so acides is fluid buildup in a cavity
um
Due to and it's and understand the mechanism of acides is not fully understood
There's just some um some thought processes and how acides occurs
um
It's not some people believe that it's the cell membranes opening um and
um fluid escaping from the cells from the
interest but in
Tera cellular spaces to the x-ray cellular spaces
Um, none of that's been proven
It's so there's just some speculation of how that occurs
Uh, would you take the fed med protocol and ever iverbector?
Yes, some people do yep
We have a lot of people taking fed med and iverbector that does work on two different pathways
um
so
uh
you can
any other questions?
Everybody having family over this weekend
making that turkey and stuffing, mashed potatoes,
corn,
wild rice,
squash,
that's our menu.
Going to family members' houses, that's nice.
oh my god or the other day i said you know we take one of the best turkeys i ever had is when we
went to your house about
it was about eight years ago and you brined to the turkey because we don't usually brine the turkey
i said that was so good i said maybe it was just so good because we went to your house
we laughed and we laughed
and they're still coming over to our cell
that happened
when hiking, well that's a great thing to do since you guys are away from home
that will be nice.
All right, well i wish you guys all a very happy things. Give me there's so much to be thankful for
just try to remind yourself to wake up every day and just
thank the Lord for
giving you the ability to take a breath and
that he's got something for you today as he's got you alive today
so there's a purpose in everything.
Know that you are blessed already tremendously
stay focused on that. Know that i love you and i pray for all of you and i will talk to you all
next week. Bye bye